and uh and kevin obviously you're like
not just a stand-up you're like a
stand-up superstar you sell out arenas
all over the world the best of our time
[Applause]
but what's nice to know is it
wasn't always like that i don't know
like
what was it what did you perform you
performed at a seafood festival
i mean which what [__] show you want to
know about
that i think they wanted was it crap i
had a crab fest
what is that in the beginning of comedy
you're not you're not performing in in
luxury you know venues wherever they
feel that they can build the stage and
make money is where you're going
so there was a crab fest
we're gonna book some talent comedian
talent
and i was like all right well you know
i'm available
i don't know if you guys have ever tried
to tell a joke while people cracking
crabs
it's not the best environment i mean
literally the frustration that comes
from not being able to open a crab
you're not funny at the same time the
stuff that you hear
i remember hearing a woman an older lady
who was like
she was cracking crabs because this is
how you crack crack
she was looking at me and she's like
cracking the crab i tell a joke and the
joke doesn't work and i remember this
lady just going
oh no
[Laughter]
i don't think i would much rather be
booed
the disappointment from her voice and
this
oh no she said baby it was like oh no
baby
i said i made a mistake with my choice
of
life like i'm not doing it wrong i i
mean
you know look the the the hardship that
i went through has helped
help build me into the person i am today
where i i can take so much
but i've been through it all i was i was
hit in the face with a buffalo wing
[Applause]
uh it was it was a it was actually a
male strip club
that they shut down for comedy for the
first half
so it was like there was a bunch of it
was ladies in there
and you know it was just supposed to be
us performing for these women that were
riled up first thing i got on stage
when they introduced me and this lady
was like pull it out i say hey
hey hey that's not me i'm not here for
that
i'm here to entertain he's a joke
i know who's got kids i start i start
trying to merge into kid material
there's one dude from the back i just
remember this dude from the back he was
like that's enough
and he just threw a buffalo wing at me
they landed hit me put me in the cheek a
little bit of sauce gala
right here buffalo sauce is hot
i sauce that it was a woman with a deep
voice so i was like who threw it
who threw it because at the end of that
i'm a man i'm a man first don't
disrespect me
he stood up he was like i did it and i i
contemplated just taking my clothes off
[Applause]
i collect yeah well i i collect um stuff
from movies uh that
some of the movies i've done but really
mainly star trek memorabilia because i
love star trek
oh such a nerd have you seen me have you
never been in a stream now i've never
been in a star trek but i love the
original series so i have
like i have the gorn head from the
original series from the episode arena
where i know
from star trek we're going to give you
the golden house oh wow okay do you have
any of the boulders do you get any of
the boulders i don't have any of the the
light boulders yeah
the paper mache no but i have spock's
ears from yeah well they actually not
they
are yeah we know what they are they're
worth yeah very good
uh but um bridesmaids you did do a lot
of kind of proper bonding on bridesmaids
didn't
you like party nights and stuff we did
we did a pre
uh recipe my co-writer annie and i had
the idea to get all the girls together
plus the script supervisor wardrobe just
all like the women on the film
40. there were a lot of people 40 women
it was
it was pitched to me as research because
initially there was a scene
where we went to a gentleman's
entertainment
yeah and then we went to we went to a
strip club
um and we watched the show they didn't
vignettes
they did vinny there was like backdraft
yeah it wasn't that it would all come
out and like firemen stuff and then it
was like right like everything had the
same theme and everything involved it
seemed like every number had a duster
everything had a long trench coat a lot
of equipment but they didn't do that
do you remember the matrix one yeah
there was somebody was playing neo
wonderfully long trenches and guys in
suits and everybody had these very cheap
glasses on
but i couldn't figure out the one guy
had a huge
huge thick rope around his waist and i
was like
i have not seen the matrix in a while i
couldn't figure out
you know couldn't we we're all like
what's the rope about i don't remember a
rope in the matrix
and they're like doing these
synchronized dancing it's like all this
a close is coming off we're like
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't get what the rope is about and
then the big move comes where you know
the bullets come and he does like the
back bend
clearly this professional dancer could
not do a back bend
so the big move was like all of a sudden
it's like oh and somebody
off stage is clearly holding the ropes
[Laughter]
saturday night live also was a big
bonding thing now
because christian do you know leslie and
and
get cake we
met i think we met when i hosted
oh no we did a movie together um then we
worked together after that
after that okay yeah okay but now you
guys are still in sacramento live which
most people i'm sure no but it's a it's
a big comedy sketch show
in in america but how long have you
worked together for how many years now
it's been two after one right
it's been three maybe three it's been
three um after the first year
leslie and my name is kate mckinnon and
she uh
i know that but uh she came up to me and
she said
after a year of knowing me
you all right kate middleton
[Laughter]
and were you joking uh no i was not and
i was like mckenna i was like who's
middleton then she was like a princess
[Applause]
[__]
you did some great characters on
saturday night live you're justin bieber
justin bieber is spookily accurate thank
you so much
you've done it in front of him haven't
you i have not you haven't have not
breached yet
um i met him before because he hosted
snl once
and then uh that was before i started
doing an impression of him but i was so
struck by how
this was before he got really beefy for
those calvin klein ends and now he looks
like
you know a big beefcake but um he was
really he was very delicate and a very
tender beautiful just
such a beautiful face and such a big big
hat
such big clothes and just the most
beautiful and i
i am a huge fan of his and i love it now
you have a special way of
a special way of preparing the face
haven't you yes
um yes you you want to look
as though you've done something wrong
but like
[Music]
so now how old are you now i'm 77
and uh oh don't look oh
don't don't that is
all that i think they applaud because
they know they're going to live longer
than me
in new york day plus that means there'll
be a new apartment on the market soon
i hate when people say like uh oh
they're 77 years young
i met vanessa uh vanessa feltz and she
said to me
here's jones she's 77 years young and i
want to say and here's vanessa and she's
350 pounds things
sucks and you have to face it
and you have these i've been on this
show with some of these
older women that still try to look good
no names goldie hawn
she's my friend and she says to me
would you believe i got a grown-up
daughter and you go yes
and lower your skirt your nipples are
showing i mean
there goes the goldy horn booking
no age sucks said you gotta face it
yeah but is it because america is really
so youth obsessed i mean how and and in
the film you show
you know kind of that it is hard for a
woman of your age to get
the job it's beyond difficult the only
jobs
really left now for women unless they
get friendly with people to do
films
the only jobs that are really
commercials i just thank god
my i made my yearly nut this year on a
product called girly which is for dry
vagina
and it's um
well anyone knows the heartbreak of dry
vaginas
[Applause]
i was perfect for it
three jewish men are trying to rent my
uterus instead of going to miami
[Laughter]
and this thank god for these commercials
there's one called zestra
has that come here yet
it's like women's uh viagra has that
happened here yet
it's women's viagra and they have this
big discussion with me
should they make it in pill form this is
honest to god truth it was in the
newspapers
pill form or cream because they didn't
know which
would do better and they finally decide
these idiots will do it in cream because
if it's in pill form
in a bar a man can drop it in a woman's
drink
and she won't know it but if you're in a
bar and a guy goes so where you from
you really were blue coke weren't you i
wasn't yeah at the place you showed
which was next door to heisham nuclear
power station
the thing is i got cena because i was i
worked at a really good one
in yarmouth great yarmouth got sacked
which is another story
and then uh was sacked and then and was
sent to we'll move on to that in a
minute
but uh you sent it this way sent to that
one as a sort of punishment it was like
uh
you you're going to morkum to do six
months because you have just
you've just done something what have you
done well
something that was considered cheeky in
the 70s but now is illegal
it was actually an incident where it was
my first attempt at stan comedy
and what happened was i i'd always
wanted to do stand-up comedy i didn't
have the guts to do it
i got very drunk i had a go at doing it
as a blue coat my mate said to me
just copy all the other comedians at
pontins and steal their jokes
and basically talk to the front row so
you're supposed to say where are you
from they say scotland you say who paid
for your holiday
where you from wales you make a noise
like a sheep rubbish jokes right
but i said that's terrible he said don't
worry you're just padding what you're
doing is you're looking for comedy gold
which is where you're from they say kent
and you say what did you call me right
now at pontins this used to take the
roof off right
so i tried it but i was very drunk
so i go on stage and i say
where are you from this bloke says
scotland
i can't remember the joke i
say hello then i said to
where you from the guy says wales i
black out and i go
hi i panic
and then i say anyone in from kent
and this bloke shouts out me
and i said well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
we loved you as the genie in aladdin oh
that was fun so we thought we might have
our very own
genie on the show tonight so uh is there
anyone in the audience who fancies a go
at being a genie oh look at them okay
try and try you
uh what what's your name ewan sorry what
you june
his name is urine
[Applause]
nice to have you here thank you no no
worries can i hear you let it take me
this frightening i know don't piss off
you and
okay think of a magic word right
something you know it's just you magic
word and that camera three
is going to do a kind of zoom crash on
you so so when i say go
you and you just do your magic word okay
so you and
go hi graham
[Applause]
wow how grandma i feel like we're in the
middle of a telethon right now
you and his learned to say hi graham
thanks to your dollars
please help you'll learn another phrase
by the end of the show
should we try another boy oh
actually you're wearing blue already
let's try you yeah okay so into that
camera your magic world what's your name
nick g nick okay
a friend of you okay
number three and go alakazam
[Applause]
it wow almost too good it was a bit like
you're you're very good at that
yeah alakazam time to dance
now i'm gonna dance with you and and
goodnight
[Applause]
okay
so i'm just going to get my genie to
help me okay hang on oh yes
because i forgot all about poor
creatures
[Applause]
good nick good oh there he is
okay nick ready i need i need a lovely
funky dj
console please good work
good work nick okay i tell you what nick
you
you can come back into the studio come
back to the shooter you can help us in
this thing okay there you go well done
[Music]
right here we go here we go it's the
robin and graham road show
hello sir gloves okay you're over there
now well done
so there's a mic there now nick i've got
some music
[__] put a shout out right now nick b
now for the blue people [__] keep it
real get ready for an alakazam
[Applause]
now i gotta many tingles so it's the
robin and graham road show
can you do a jingle a live jingle bell
welcome to the
robin and graham radio show
very good
good evening robin good evening graham
welcome back once again we got some
shout outs
i got one going out right now to stephen
buck he wants to shout out to jess
who's a best friend and he says stop
texting him
he's not interested yay you're
listening to the robin and roadshow how
cause i
am no you tit the jingle
welcome to the robin and graham
michelle smith what's a shout out to
esther best friend
that bloke you pulled don't worry about
trying to remember his name
you can do so much better yeah
whoa where's marlin marlon
oh there he is marlon ready we're gonna
say we'd like to shout out to his friend
gregoire
don't worry girls love that you have got
a third nipple oh
three nipples abc way to go
show it shut up
[Applause]
first of all i'm not a circus freak
secondly i will get my third nipple out
on the condition that robin williams
comes and touches it
this better be a real nipple
all right ready here we go ready ready
let's see
oh please please let it be a nipple
i have a third ball too
ready ready here we go okay ow oh
did i touch it i did
[Applause]
play with my third nipple girl you've
never had fun till you go third
once you touch the third nipple things
get crazy
i get two nipples going but when the
third goes
[Music]
the third nipple goes and then my fourth
penis jumps out
ladies and gentlemen please thank my
guests tonight the fantastic
mr robin williams
thank you
[Music]
you